the thing about life
is decision making there are a lot of
you know like like i came up in an
environment where they say
you know your environment makes you and
dictates what you do i was in an
environment where everybody was doing
the wrong thing and i was able to say
i don't want to do that i don't feel
like killing i don't think it's the
right karmic thing to do see the thing
about life
is you have the ability to make
decisions so if somebody tells you
something stupid
you could choose to run with it or that
flag should be able to flash and say i'm
not running with it that's the choice
that people have the ability to make
you can that is you can be influenced
but ultimately what god did give us
is the ability to have a point of view a
perspective
to stand behind it you know you can be
insecure or be secure about it you know
you can stand out or stand in a crowd
but it is a choice a choice that you as
a person can make you can't blame
your um actual actions on anything else
but yourself
recognize what really makes you happy if
you feel like you lose and you lose it
doesn't matter what other people feel
so i know how it feels to be perceived
as winning and be feeling like uh i'm
losing
i stopped living according to what
people wanted me to do
i started living according to what
actually made me happy
like if you're in a situation that don't
make no sense then get out of it don't
make it make sense
one plus one always equals two if you're
not happy change your life
but you're not worried about what you
put in your body you're gonna put some
[ __ ] that you know that other people
make
right and then on a corporate level you
don't trust corporate but you buy
corporate food
every weakness i turn in that's
perceived as a weakness
i've made a conscious effort to turn it
into a strength so
if i'm in an environment where survival
is hard
and and i survive it then i'm going to
use that to showcase
my strength and as a strength monetize
the fact that
learning from this experience could make
you do better in your future you
understand i'm i'm diabetic
so instead of looking at that as a
weakness i look at it listen i must be
diabetic god gave it to me as because i
i have a platform to showcase it and
make everyone's lives better
you know everything happens for a reason
anything bad could be good as a yin and
yang to everything it's about your
perspective and the energy and the
efforts you put forth to it
wealth is happiness completely is how
much you laugh and how much the people
you love laugh
and that's really what love is how much
time you spend like
sending money back to somebody like a
child it's not considered love because
kids don't care about money i remember
when i was a child
all i wanted for christmas was for my
parents for my moms to get back with my
dad
and i didn't i wasn't able to give that
to my any one of my children
so i still have work to do you know
i haven't hit that wealthiness because i
haven't been able to
take that most important pain to a child
and take that away from my children and
haven't broke that cycle
that would be wealth if my children
don't have to pick a side
if they don't have to watch us fight if
they don't have to
tune out because they don't want to hear
us argue you know what i'm saying
what's going to be the secret there what
are you trying to get in the play
finding the right woman for the right
reasons so it's great because i was
ready
really able to recognize it in raquel i
was like nah this time
i'm staying we're doing everything
together well she's i
i enjoy this too much so it's always
looking at it from my kids perspective
my woman's perspective
it's i think i've learned to take my
eyeballs out of my head and put it in
theirs for a second to see what they see
and what would make them comfortable
over me as a boss
your job is to think about your business
and your staff
before you think about yourself it's the
same thing a dad
does or the head of a family so
i guess me being conscious of these
things at 47 being evolved enough to
take the time to
appreciate that that's to me is wealth
you know uncompromised great quality of
living
like i prefer not to have to live in a
house that's not big and all the
luxuries that i've worked so hard to get
but i think every circumstance rockell
has
and i've been in we've been equally
happy whether it's a big house or a
studio apartment
i think the death of my mother probably
got me really focused
and i understood that there wasn't going
to be anyone there to take care of me i
had to take care of myself
and just out of respect for her life and
all the things she did to make me a
better person
i had to apply all those things so you
know at like
17 my mother died when i was 16 at 17
you know i was running the streets so
heavy
and it was getting so critical that i
put myself in boarding school you know i
figured out how to get a scholarship and
because of
the ability that my mother gave me to
articulate what's on my mind to read
to write you know to not be afraid and
also
i was you know boxing so i got went to
the boys club and
they were giving out scholarships for
you know you took a test i passed the
test and
you know i made it and uh i would i was
just always able to to put myself in a
better place
i never let anybody else control my
destiny my mom's taught me
to uh make things happen on my own not
to depend on anybody and if i have an
opinion to speak on it
i'm used to living by discipline where
all i know is to survive you have to
have honor and it feels right
you know and i just never been one to
consider cheating a win
i i don't think looking like you're
winning is winning because really all i
care about is what i think about myself
not what other people think
some of us acting like bosses right but
some of us really are right some of us
looking like bosses right but some of us
really are
[ __ ] if you're a boss where's your
office and it better be yours you better
be paying the rent right you see some p
l let me see you pay some employees let
me see you broke for a second because
you ain't collect no bread
you know what that 30 is all of that
type right if you're a boss you know
about pain
and all that you know about paying
people before yourself right all that
you know about
every time you start a new business like
when you make a movie and and like we
make movies yeah i'm going to take to
get the money back
years years
think about how the [ __ ] is like
everyone knows like this kid puts his
own money up even for his own movie
man of his own yeah but he broke yeah
you know i'm broke
because i got money in equity in
businesses like i don't want
to drop records i drop i drop businesses
you understand what i'm saying like
i sell companies like [ __ ] sell records
that's my game i play a different game
right right so when they say how many
records you saw i don't know how many
companies i saw so rockwell rockefeller
i sell companies there's men that don't
sell companies their whole life don't
know what it means to sell records
and i do bars but it's true you know
what i mean that's like a real
fact you know what i mean yeah yeah and
every time i sell one that means i
started from scratch i mean i had to be
broke i had to
feel some pain i had to lose sustained
looked up
and then go sell it and make some bread
pay off some bills and start again there
it is
you flip because i learned that from the
street like yo i could buy something for
20
and sell it for 40. right you know if i
break it down i buy something for 40
break it down 78
right that's just what i did i made a
record company so that i could do a
clothing company a clothing company so i
could do a television network right
flip flip flip next i'm gonna flip forth
and you're gonna keep going you it's
hard to keep a real boss down now well
nobody never been down that's the thing
they can make you look a certain way
right but bottom line is
i don't know man i like when i do my
instagram i'm not outside i'm in the
house i'm in my office
i'm not trying to front i'm not posing
like my natural life looks like a
movie right so at any time i've never
had a problem i ran around the world and
opened
up galleries all over the world like i
got dd-172 and tribeca poppington in low
east side
i got one in burbank one in uh hong kong
pohang fung yeah no one ever wants to
talk about that right
all the cultural things i'm the dna of
what i want the culture to be at some
point and i want us to be tasteful
we want us to be evolved i want us to
deal with things like men not emotion
i want us to really be rich not look
rich i want us to be friends i want us
to stick together i want to take care of
our kids
i want us to take care of women i want
that to be cool i want selling out to be
sucker
i want looking the other way to be
suckers i want treating women bad to be
suckers
right with little girls to be suckers i
don't want people to be
with people even though they do do
the other way got to stop you got to be
accountable why are you
scared to have them conversations
you're asking me about fear and i don't
even know what that is the only thing i
fear is fear
so you asking me about a concept i don't
understand that's not that's no bueno
that's not even because
i don't want to talk people will hide
and just follow when you speak
people like when you speak boss you
don't understand fear what language is
that
fear what does that mean right you know
what i'm saying
what what is that you got to translate
that to me i don't even what is that
i've never understood boston
[Applause]
what does that mean right like if your
boss fear doesn't even come into it
number one uh if you want to be a
professional it doesn't come to you you
got to go get it
because everybody else is trying to go
get it and it means you're trying to be
the best in the world
so that means you have to really work
hard but
don't let your music and be so selfish
about your artisticness and chasing your
dream
that you neglect to take care of what's
important and
not make time and miss your family if
you give an honest effort you give 100
you should win i haven't seen anybody
play honest and give 100 and lose i've
never seen that
i've seen people play cheat and quit
and fail i've seen that happen but i've
never seen someone give a hundred
percent
play the game right you get knocked down
get back up and keep doing it and being
persistent at it
i've never seen someone lose and i
always say for any business to just even
get sustainable is going to take five
years
and after 10 years you're good forever
you understand you could last 10 years
you're a brand a1
if you you know you probably take five
years to sustain or be sustainable and
make money
but if you could last for 10 years you
should never have to worry about that
ever again when people make me the
underdog it's funny because they don't
understand what the game i'm playing
just because i'm not playing your game
or just because i'm not moving at the
pace you're moving it don't mean i'm
wrong
you know what i'm saying your money the
same witness mine and it's never been
like what i've always liked when someone
thought a record deal was dope i was
like a label deal
you understand like you got a record
deal you should have a label
you might have a tv show or you should
have a network you know that's just how
i think
i don't know any other language but boss
boss language you know what i'm saying
so when people don't talk and boss to me
i don't know what they say you know what
i'm saying it's a language it's there's
approach
languages like like people approach
things like bosses
and people approach things like workers
a lot of people don't want to be bosses
because there's so much responsibility
that come with it
you understand they're scared of it and
i always say that you understand what
i'm saying
right but a boss only can think about it
in boss terms
so if somebody says they want to get in
business some people might say well i
need somebody to give me a job
that's not a boy's thought right a boss
says if i want to get better my thought
is if i want to get in business
i'm going to create the business figure
i'm going to buy the business
you understand what i'm saying then i'm
going to do the business but i'm not
trying to be hired
my approach is always going to be bossy
you know someone that's not used to
being the boss
his thought process ain't possible he
don't have boss thoughts
fluent balls do you understand what i'm
saying right yeah before winning boss
and if you don't talk to me and boss i
don't understand what you said
and people will think you're an [ __ ]
because they're like oh that's not how i
post writers right
do you understand what i'm saying that's
i'm not celebrating that
that you got to do your boss talk is
like i speak that yeah
you can tell what somebody else talks
boss just why their approach on thing
and someone that talks boss doesn't
speak any other language
i only talk boss it's all about effort
and what you could visualize in your
mind you know if you can't think it
could happen and if you don't have
confidence that it's gonna happen it
ain't gonna happen
so if you doubt yourself like you know i
box or at least i used to
i'm not getting in the ring unless i
know i'm a win or else i already lost
and i look at everything i do like that
i'm winning and there is nothing
it's 100 everything is about perspective
and what you consider a win
you know some people think they're
winning because
other people think they're winning even
though they don't feel good about what
they're doing
they're like oh you think i'm winning so
that must mean i'm winning but i feel
like
that's not winning you know you have to
know what makes you happy what you
consider
when not everybody's win is the same you
know what i'm saying but
people like to fit in with aws but not
me i know what my w's are
if you want to know how to become your
own boss like dame dash check out the
video right there next to me i think
you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there i don't believe i should have to
be nice
to get somebody to give me something if
my product is good no matter how i act
you will pay for it
like people approaching like bosses and
people approach things like workers